un petit mois jimmy bonjour bonjour aux
deux jours sans on n'a rien fait vous
êtes fatigué mon cochon oui et j'ai faim
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un an j'ai soit riche
ou je fais de la sous-couche mal un peu
de soupe aux choux qui sait si bien
faire au bâti leur activité de
patrouille
les premières fraises lefranc floch
oui qu'est-ce que tu l'appelles magazine
aujourd'hui vous allez au cinéma c'était
bien assez intéressant que tu as vu j'ai
eu la rage des corps qui ont soif par
contre en soit c'est un film à idées sa
part de la nymphomane
as tu sais ce qu'ils arrivent à faire de
la couleur problème chez la femme
l'emprunt c'est un très grave problème
je t'explique être fiers parce que tout
d'un coup elle voit énorme et puis crac
échange tu as fait dehors des limites et
bien scotché
je comprends qu'une fois passagèrement
elle face up
oui moi je m'excuse si leurs excuses et
aussi en tête bien non ce sont les
fleurs du mâle qui s'ouvre un grand
trouble colère une bouffée de chaleur
ah tiens prends un petit coup mais la
femme dans le film elle est innocente à
la lutte
somme toute faite
on regarde dans le coup peu importe au
flipper flop la voilà la femme érotisme
comme tuvalu min exagère mais ta sale
coup à la femme ann m plus un homme mais
l'homme souffre je suis passé l'oral si
le pacs est rouge où chaque catalogue ou
pour la femme
oui mais vous signez oui venez dans la
chambre j'ai de la monnaie dans ma
chambre tu es donc pas tout ramener à
l'épée dti j'abuse désabusé provoque
heures comme toi ah bon ça m'est égal
cinq minutes c'est un râleur
quelque chose non si le climat
aphrodisiaques il envoûte non stop pas
se trouve pas c'est peut-être dans leur
riche où ça commence comme ça tu vois
cinq heures l'heure de vénus la
toxi-infection camara va opposer psg le
plus mince en dépit d'une tâche les
casseurs c'est de la démagogie me
laisser chez wam
j'apportais tango et puis un petit
bouquet surprise mais c'était fort ça a
logiquement emmanuel madame je m'appelle
emmanuel petit chef jambes c'est vous je
vous reconnais ça m'a fait du bien vous
savez je suis en pleine forme c'est tout
en plaisir de voir qu'elle est
commerçant qui sont commerçants
mathieu sa chair mais non les ogm
tu sais donner un petit coup de main en
passant bas que ça fait toujours plaisir
et bien cela le service pendant la
prochaine elle a le bras ce qu à nos
braves qui retrouvait hier à la famille
qui ferait pas se fonder étrangers comme
celui-ci pour les nôtres utilise non
chez ces projets nos épaules et ne cédez
pour les noces du wifi pour les données
par john robert soulas n'y a pas de
pardon n'y a pas de pardon 3 l'animal
non bouchers coiffeurs gillot tu écoutes
tu trouves mois la fautive et nightfall
comparaison est certes on porte un jeune
à sa diète nom et rappelle par contre
elle est légale est la falaise le grand
vertige après la marée montante
le rough luxe et reflux qui suit même
fluxs ne se souciait pas du xxe pas de
refus
ce programme j'ai connu ma première et
coquillages les visites crevettes
l'école mon maillot de bain deux pièces
manquaient pour tes bretelles blé oui
mais pour eux c'était direct sarah
serviette adore
oui une fois plus le froid plein sommes
peut-être c'est pas cher voire tu as osé
frapper là je vais t'en fiches mois de
la symphonie no 10 heures j'ai peut-être
pas mais j'ai la rage des corps qu'on
soit bien joindre a nommé désir j'ai vu
jouer temps car les hommes c'est
pourtant look
j'ai dû jouer à ce putin j'ai vu jouer
l'atout la 7ème compagnie j'ai vu jouer
oss 117
j'ai vu jouer histoire d'eau et tende la
main
les dents de la mer est mort au caire
c'est mon grand requin blanc se tient
prêt nouveau à s'émerveiller
no votre came city